no no no
um
[Música]
hola christina
buenos días hola buenos días soy
christine de khan academy mexico y
gracias por venir y feliz su regreso a
clases
sí exacto bienvenidos todos
felicidades por este inicio de clases
hoy vamos a tener una capacitación muy
interesante muy importante porque lo que
queremos hacer con ustedes es justo
ayudarnos en este regreso a clase para
compartir con ustedes varios tips varias
ideas para que el regreso a clases sea
mucho más fácil mucho más eficiente para
todos mi nombre es para ti garcía yo
trabajo para detective y para el trabajo
muy de la mano de khan academy esta
sesión se va a tratar de preguntas y
respuestas sobre algunos temas que
ahorita está planteando khan academy y
que como les comentamos el objetivo es
hacerles la vida más fácil hasta no
ayudarlos en este regreso a clases en
este inicio del año escolar 2018 2019
entonces comenzamos no sé si quieras
agradecer a
o añadir algo más es christina
no está bien
ok nos están viendo la presentación
sí perfecto pues bienvenidos nuevamente
como les comentamos el objetivo de khan
academy es acompañarlos apoyarlos no
para que puedan axilizar los resultados
académicos de todos sus alumnos durante
este año escolar
la misión de khan academy recuerden es
ofrecer una educación de primer nivel
para cualquier alumno en cualquier lugar
y en cualquier momento
recuerden que cada academia es una
plataforma gratuita no entonces eso nos
permite llegar a mucho más escuelas a
muchos más alumnos
este es el enlace para la presentación
en caso de que no tengan su dispositivo
a la mano únicamente pueden tomar una
foto con su celular o también una foto
con su mismo computador para que más
adelante puedan acceder a la
presentación y la pueden bajar y guardar
si tienen ahorita su dispositivo
lo ideal sería que ingresen a este
enlace para que entren a la presentación
y ya desde ahora puedan guardar g
o punto g l diagonal t mayúscula que
doble un mayúscula efe mayúscula o
mayúscula v mayúscula si puedes anotar
este enlace en la en el chat estaría muy
bien kristinn gracias voy a darle unos
minutitos para que puedan entrar y
comenzamos
bueno antes que nada queremos
presentarles esta página de soporte
técnico de khan academy en español aquí
en esta página la verdad esta
maravillosa van a encontrar respuestas a
las preguntas que normalmente tienen los
profesores respecto a la plataforma no
las preguntas más comunes y también van
a recibir todo el apoyo que ustedes
necesitan para este regreso a clases
basta con la sele clic aquí les
recomiendo que la salven que la guarden
en sus favoritos y de esto se trata la
página no aquí nos pone como podemos
ayudar
previo resolución a los problemas más
comunes que tenemos los docentes cuando
entramos a la plataforma preguntas
frecuentes preguntas a la comunidad aquí
les damos varias pistas trucos ayuda no
para que como les digo este inicio a
clases sea de lo más suave
noel y resulte muy eficiente y efectivo
para todos entonces los invito a que a
que visite la página trae
habrá mucha información útil para
nosotros entonces está creada y pensada
en ustedes no preguntas frecuentes no
misión en khan academy como le doy
seguimiento cuáles son los
requerimientos básicos para crear un
usuario
hay un poco de todo no entonces
errores como que a veces nos pasa que
hay algún error en alguna respuesta de
algún ejercicio o en algún vídeo todo
eso también lo podemos reportar no y
también estamos anexando varios
artículos no ver diferentes artículos al
respecto de cada uno de los diferentes
temas que tratamos en esta página
entonces los invitamos a que la usen la
que la vean a que investiguen un poco
más de qué se trata esta página
ok esta es la agenda de hoy vamos a
recorrer nuevamente este y de una manera
un poco más rápida
la plataforma cuáles son las cosas más
básicas que yo ahorita en el inicio a
clases tengo que hacer lo primero
recuerden es
para ser más eficientes y más efectivos
borrar todas las clases eliminar todas
las clases que ya no estamos usando en
este año escolar es nuestro primer paso
deshacernos de todo eso que ya no
estamos utilizando para que no se
acumulen en nuestra cuenta
recuerden que al borrar una cuenta estoy
borrando una cuenta no una clase perdón
no una cuenta no entonces vamos a
eliminar
clases antiguas y vamos a ver sobre todo
el proceso de cómo creó clases nuevas
para este inicio de año escolar y como
invito a mis alumnos nosotros vamos a
ver esta parte para esto le voy a salir
de la plataforma de la presentación para
entrar directamente a la plataforma otra
parte que vamos a ver hoy como parte de
la agenda es a que tengo que hacer yo
para comenzar no ya con el pie derecho a
utilizar
khan academy como una herramienta base
en mi salón de clases y la tercera parte
vamos a dejar un tiempo para preguntas y
respuestas aquí estaremos también con
christine que tendrá la oportunidad de
responder todas las preguntas que tengan
entonces me voy a salir voy a entrar a
la plataforma
déjeme casierra y bueno estamos aquí en
la plataforma recuerden que para poder
entrar lo primero que tienen que hacer
es crear su cuenta no para aquellos que
son nuevos en el canal de mí que nunca
han entrado les vamos a enseñar
rápidamente cómo entrar a crear su
cuenta para aquellos nuevos recuerden
que lo primero que tienen que hacer es
ir a este enlace van a entrar a lo que
es ese punto
khan academy punto org que es la
plataforma que está ya en español
esto les vamos a pedir a todos que
entren a este enlace ese punto tan
academy punto org en caso de que ustedes
nunca hayan entrado que sea la primera
vez que están con nosotros entonces lo
único que ustedes van a hacer es
maestros inicien aquí
y yo le sugiero que de las tres opciones
que tienen utilicen mejor registrarse
con su correo eléctrica electrónico
porque luego facebook borramos la cuenta
etcétera entonces van a hacer clic con
registrar le con mi correo van a poner
su correo electrónico ya sea el de la
institución en la que trabajan o usa el
personal van a poner su nombre su
apellido y van a crear una contraseña
que les recomiendo la noten en un lugar
muy visible un lugar donde ustedes
recuerden y van a crear una contraseña
con 8 caracteres traten de que esas
letras símbolos etcétera y una vez que
tengan toda la información completa le
van a dar clic en regístrate así de
sencillo es si ustedes ya tienen una
cuenta con khan academy lo único que van
a hacer es click en iniciar sesión e
íbamos a poner nuestro correo
electrónico con el que nos registramos
y la contraseña también que utilizamos
para registrarnos
y le damos click en iniciar sesión
clic aquí se abre ya la página de khan
academy y entramos a la plataforma
entonces los maestros nuevos que nunca
han tenido una cuenta que la acaban de
crear automáticamente van a entrar aquí
recuerden que aquí no van a tener nada
porque estas son clases que yo tengo
creadas de antes ok y simplemente aquí
lo van a tener ustedes vacíos y ya
tienen alguna clase esta es su página
principal donde van a encontrar todas
sus clases como docentes nuevamente
recordatorios rápidos
recuerden que al hacer clic al academy
siempre voy a regresar a la página
principal que yo elegí para que fuera la
principal y recuerden que aquí en su
nombre ustedes van a poder cambiar de su
rol de maestro a su rol de alumno
recuerden que en can academy yo puedo
ser maestro y tener mis clases pero a la
vez poder ser alumno y pertenecer a
algunas clases no entonces yo puedo
siempre cambiar aquí si elijo página del
aprendizaje se va a cambiar mi rol al de
alumno que va a ser ésta
y aquí yo puedo ver tareas los tutores
que tengo etcétera si es que estoy
tomando yo una clase de con otro
profesor sobre cálculo avanzado etcétera
no y siempre regreso a cala de tutor
para realizar a mi página de maestro
donde selecciono y rápidamente se los
voy a decir donde selección lo cual
quiero que sea mi página principal
entonces cuando yo entro aquí ok le hago
clic en mi nombre y me voy a
configuración de mi cuenta al hacer clic
en configuración de mi cuenta
me voy hacia abajo aquí me voy a
asegurar de que yo tenga activo mi rol
de estudiante y mi rol de tutor y acá
página del inicio voy a seleccionar cuál
es esa página que yo quiero que sea mi
página principal mi página base yo les
recomiendo siempre que elija la de tutor
y van a hacer clic en guardar cambios
automáticamente siempre que hagan clic
acá las bayas los va a llevar a su
página de tutor
ahora vamos a ver rápidamente como
agregó una clase recuerdan todos y para
aquellos que no lo han visto antes esto
es un proceso de tres pasos muy
sencillos voy a hacer clic en agregar
una clase y aquí vamos a ponerle el
nombre de nuestra clase ustedes ahorita
ya tienen claro el grado escolar la
materia que van a dar en ese grado
etcétera todos vamos a poner por ejemplo
yo a poner de moda y voy a poner tercer
de los porque esto es una demostración
tercer tercero vamos a poner período
por decir un ejemplo no traten de ser lo
más específico con sus clases para que
puedan identificarlos muy bien una vez
que comience el año escolar aquí siempre
podemos importar desde google classroom
si ya estamos trabajando con google
classroom es muy sencillo porque esto
automáticamente nos cuenta nos conecta
con google classroom podemos desde aquí
nada más
seleccionar qué clase con qué clase
quiero sincronizar mi clase de khan
academy yo ya puedo elegir con qué clase
quiero y si no estoy trabajando con
google claro me quedo acá pongo el
nombre de mi clase y doy siguiente
automáticamente amanecer aquí bueno qué
año o qué curso vas a dar en esta clase
cuál va a ser tu curso y recuerden que
tenemos matemáticas por tema puede ser a
aritmética pre algebra álgebra etcétera
o puedo seleccionar por grado escolar no
en aquí sería ya como una visión o de en
este año escolar vamos a cubrir todos
los requerimientos de primero secundaria
o de segundo o de tercero vamos a
ponerle tercero de secundaria recuerden
también que yo puedo agregar más sosa yo
puedo dar seleccionar segundo de
secundaria y tercero porque porque
quizás yo pueda empezar a dar segundo de
secundaria y al final del ciclo escolar
comience a ver algunos temas de tercero
a lo que voy es que yo puedo seleccionar
más de un tema yo puedo seleccionar a la
mejor preal gebrán pero después voy a
también a comenzar ya con fundamentos de
álgebra y también esto yo lo puedo
editar más adelante una villa creada mi
clase siempre tengo la oportunidad
recuerden de cambiar pues voy a
seleccionar tercero de secundaria
tenemos también biología química física
ingeniería y le voy a dar clic ahora
llegó al tercer paso que es el más
importante que es agregar a mis
estudiantes y ustedes ahora que están
comenzando el ciclo escolar yo lo que
les sugiero es que una vez que cree en
sus clases y les pongan un nombre y les
asigna en el tema la materia que le van
a dar a esa clase
teniendo a todos sus alumnos juntos en
clase mi sugerencia es que les los
inviten a través de este código cada vez
que ustedes generan una clase recuerden
maestros siempre se genera un código
especial para esta clase que voy a hacer
estando ahí con todos mis alumnos en
clase voy a anotar en el pizarrón esto
khan academy punto or diagonal join les
voy a pedir a mis alumnos que entren
recuerden puede ser desde su celular
desde su computador se están usando
chromebook lo que sea una vez que ellos
entran a esto les gusta es también van a
notar esto este código en el pizarrón en
letras bien grandes todo esto lo único
que le van a decir a los alumnos vayan
acá
y ellos van a entrar a esta página y
aquí automáticamente les dice únete a
una clase y lo único que ellos tienen
que hacer aquí es anotar la clave de la
clase que ustedes van a poner en el
pizarrón y le van a decir él le van a
hacer clic únete a la clase
automáticamente les dice ha ingresado
con éxito a la clase esta es la manera
maestros más sencilla de agregar a los
estudiantes la verdad para mí es la más
recomendable pueden también imprimir las
instrucciones éstas todavía las tenemos
en inglés pero lo único que pueden hacer
es anotar el código pedirles que vayan a
esta dirección darles el código acá y
que peguen este este pedacito de papel
está en su cuaderno para que si más
adelante se salen de la clase pierden
sus datos etcétera siempre tengan la
información de cómo regresar a su clase
y otra manera también de invitar a los
alumnos puede ser cómo les digo importar
desde google classroom si es que están
utilizando google claro o pueden bien
enviar una cuenta por una invitación por
correo electrónico aquí basta con que
ustedes pongan el correo del alumno
y me inviten a su estudiante entonces
una vez que ustedes invitan
automáticamente en la clase queda crear
obvio que para invitar por correo
electrónico necesitamos tener todos los
correos electrónicos de nuestros alumnos
a la mano entonces por eso toman un poco
más de tiempo y la verdad es que mi
experiencia es que después de cierto
tiempo sigo persiguiendo a alumnos para
que acepten y entren a mi clase no
porque yo ya perdieron el correo o me
piden que se les vuelva a enviar
etcétera entonces mi método más sugerido
digamos es a través del código de la
clase una vez que invitan a sus alumnos
que sus alumnos entran automáticamente
se crea la clase le sale esta ventana
diciendo bueno ya tienes tu clase creada
estos son los siguientes pasos podemos
empezar a explorar nuestra clase viendo
qué ejercicios qué vídeos qué artículos
tengo para mi clase y empezar a
asignarlos a mis alumnos entonces si yo
hago clic en explorar el contenido de
tercero de secundaria porque fue el tema
que yo elegí para esta clase
una vez que abro esto este va a ser el
menú que ustedes van a ver en todas sus
clases recuerden que todas sus clases
van a contar con contenido tareas avance
actividad lista y configuración
aquí si yo hago clic en contenido aquí
se les va a abrir como yo seleccione de
tercero de secundaria aquí se les va a
abrir todos los diferentes temas y
conceptos y habilidades que nuestros
alumnos tienen que aprender durante este
ciclo escolar para poder después el año
que entra a cursar con éxito primero a
bachillerato no entonces aquí van a ver
una ecuación es cuadráticas semejanzas
transformaciones etcétera y recuerden
vamos a ver rápidamente como asigno yo
material y recursos a mis alumnos yo si
empiezo con ecuaciones lineales la
primera semana de clases porque bueno
vamos a hacer un repaso a lo mejor de lo
que vieron en segundo de secundaria
basta con que yo haga clic en el tema y
aquí yo voy a decir ok voy a ver
recuerden que en can academy yo puedo
asignar tanto vídeos como artículos
ejercicios hoy día ya tenemos
disponibles disponibles también
evaluaciones y hasta exámenes de unidad
esto ha sido material nuevo que viene
todavía enriquecer más la plataforma y
hacer nuestra vida todavía mucho más
sencilla entonces yo aquí puedo ver ok
me gusta ver este vídeo quiero ver lo
puedo hacer clic en vista previa puedo
ver de qué se trata el vídeo de no de
qué va a hablar el vídeo si me gusta le
hago clic en esta ventanita igual puedo
ver ejercicios ok y puedo empezar a ver
también incluso aquí puedo ver cómo el
alumno lo va a percibir va a percibir
estos ejercicios si yo estoy de acuerdo
hago clic aquí en el ejercicio y lo
seleccionó si entonces una vez que yo
selecciono diferentes recursos o los
recursos que yo quiero asignar hago clic
aquí automáticamente como yo tengo dos
palomeados me dice vas a asignar dos
recursos le hago clic y me abre esta
ventana y aquí
maravilloso porque me dice ok quieres
que tus estudiantes
esto también es muy nuevo trabajen con
un conjunto aleatorio de preguntas qué
quiere decir esto que todos mis alumnos
van a recibir preguntas diferentes con
esta víctima un poquito el que copien o
bien yo si yo quiero que todos los
alumnos reciban el mismo conjunto de
ejercicios voy a seleccionar esta opción
vamos a poner que trabajen todos con un
mismo conjunto de preguntas aquí yo
decido a qué clase voy a asignar estos
recursos este también es una ventaja me
permite ahorrar tiempo porque si yo
estoy enseñando a tercero periodo a abc
un periodo 1 2 y 3 pues desde aquí puedo
asignárselo a mis tres terceros o no a
todas mis clases del mismo grado que yo
está dando aquí también me permite
diferenciar porque si yo selecciono si
yo decido asignar esto únicamente a
aquellos alumnos que yo considero
necesitan este repaso voy a seleccionar
a los alumnos que lo necesitan si es
algo que yo digo quiero que todos lo
vuelvan a practicar selección
todos esto como les digo me permite
personalizar el aprendizaje y realmente
atender las necesidades específicas de
mis alumnos no entonces lo hago de una
manera fácil sencilla rápida que para mí
no requiere de más esfuerzo y tiempo
como docente no aquí pongo fecha límite
para que ya lo quiero vamos a ponerle el
viernes a que ahora es mi clase es mi
clases a las 9 yo digo quiero que estén
listos a las 9 y yo le voy a dar clic en
asignar ok automáticamente si me voy a
tareas aquí voy a tener ya mis tareas
asignadas ok si le doy clic por alumno
tengo a mis a mis alumnos y en las
tareas y le doy clic por tarea voy a
tener las tareas cuando las asigne
cuando vencen quien las está completado
aquí me sale que nadie en el momento en
que se empiezan a completar yo ya puedo
acceder a los reportes
ahora también si yo tengo contenido y
esto es importante que lo sepamos
también si yo estoy entro a contenido y
voy y digamos que en dos semanas yo
pienso en un mes pienso dar ecuaciones
cuadráticas pero ahorita tengo tiempo
para ver este los diferentes temas que
hay etcétera yo decir ok de ecuaciones
cuadráticas pues tengo tengo un vídeo
también nuevamente lo puedo ver y decir
ok este es el vídeo que a mí me interesa
que yo quiero en ético o cualquier
terminado recuerden que los vídeos la
verdad es que están espectaculares
porque son sencillos son fáciles de
entender sólo son largos sólo son
concretos entonces son de mucha ayuda
para los alumnos vamos a seleccionar
esto y también nuevamente voy a
seleccionar recuerden que siempre puedo
acceder a vista previa destacar tardando
en cargarse pero no no voy a esperar a
que lo seleccionó ok y entonces ahora lo
voy a asignar pero fíjense fíjense ahora
esto es un tema que yo planeo dar en un
mes
entonces en lugar de yo asignar
nuevamente voy a seleccionar las clases
a las que lo voy a asignar yo puedes
seleccionar 3
yo puedo seleccionar todos mis alumnos
yo puedo seleccionar en qué fecha y como
pienso darlo en unas dos semanas vamos a
calcular que para el viernes 7 de
septiembre quiero asignar esto a la
misma hora de mi clase y aquí en lugar
de hacer clic en asignar yo voy aquí a
hacer clic en guardar y asignar más
tarde con esto que estoy haciendo estoy
guardando mis tareas que podré asignar
en el momento en que yo esté listo para
asignar si yo me voy aquí a tareas
nuevamente aquí en clic por tarea tengo
las tareas activas que tienen que
entregar ya y mis tareas guardadas que
son las que voy a ciclar más adelante
llegado el momento en que yo ya estoy
lista ya estoy cubriendo este tema lo
único que yo hago es clic en asignar y
automáticamente las tareas se asignan y
van a aparecer en tareas activas
ok ahora voy a regresar aquí recuerden
haciendo clic en el logo de cada cabo y
regreso a mis clases entonces fíjense
ahora lo que voy a hacer yo aquí tengo
la clase que acabo de crear
vamos a suponer que esta clase yo ya no
la voy a usar voy a hacer clic en la
clase y como eliminó esta clase esto es
muy importante recuerden que es un paso
vital antes de que comience de que
comiencen a crear sus clases de este
curso desde este año escolar 2018 2019
hago clic en mi clase y entró nuevamente
a mi clase aquí de los de las opciones
que yo tengo el contenido tarea avanza
actividad lista y configuración voy a
hacer clic en configuración ya que
automáticamente fíjense acá me aparece
esta opción de eliminar esta clase
inmediatamente arriba de la parte
superior derecha hago clic en eliminar
esta clase me dice está seguro que
quiere eliminarla le hago clic en ok y
automáticamente esta clase queda
eliminada sano nos toman nos toma menos
de un minuto eliminar una clase
entonces si los invito los invitamos les
sugerimos que eliminen todas esas clases
muertas por llamarlo así de su cuenta
recuerden que al eliminarla su cuenta
sigue activa y abierta no están
eliminando su cuenta únicamente clases
que ya no utilizan dentro de su cuenta
preguntas hasta que christina
no hay 1er
a ver si tiene quiere un comentario
ok seguimos entonces bueno nuestro
siguiente punto en la agenda es que
tienes que hacer para empezar ya con
khan academy hay muchas cosas que están
sucediendo ahorita en khan academy todo
todo todo lo que está haciendo khan
academy con el objetivo maestros de
hacer nuestra vida como docente es mucho
más fácil no mucho más eficiente ahora
ahorita parte de los programas que están
lanzando khan academy para ayudarnos a
nosotros como maestros es este programa
de capacitación este programa de
capacitación consta de tres módulos al
final de cada uno ustedes van a recibir
un reconocimiento no por cada uno de los
módulos y el objetivo de este programa
de capacitación es hacer los maestros
estrellas maestros campeones en el uso
de esta plataforma son tres módulos muy
sencillos cortos el primero ya tuvo
lugar el primero de agosto y también el
segundo tuvo lugar ya en agosto existen
los enlaces de los webinars los cuales
éste
estamos compartiendo constantemente y
tiene pueden tener acceso ya a los no a
los vídeos de youtube sobre estos estos
dos módulos y el objetivo es como les
digo enséñales todos los trucos todos
los diferentes pasos que tienen que
hacer para crear sus cuentas para
invitar sus alumnos para empezar a
asignar contenido y para realmente
sacarle el mayor provecho a esta
plataforma durante el año escolar
realmente es como que les puedo decir yo
yo fui docente de matemáticas y de
ciencias por casi 15 años 2 entre 12 15
años el colegio americano de la ciudad
de méxico y el colegio de omán y también
en la zona méxico
esta plataforma de verdad vido y no
añadir muchísimo valor a mis clases me
permitió atender las necesidades de
muchos de mis alumnos que sentían que
eran malísimos para matemáticas lo que
odiaban la materia obviamente su grado
en frustración y desmotivación era
enorme y al poder realmente darles es
poner en sus manos de esta plataforma
ellos
pudieron ir a su paso no ir a su propio
ritmo ver los vídeos cuántas veces lo
necesitaban leer los artículos cuántas
veces lo necesitaban podían recurrir a
tips a claves etcétera para resolver
ejercicios podían practicar tanto como
ellos quisieran y fueron ganando mucha
confianza no hay mucha seguridad en la
materia y eso es algo invaluable no sólo
para ellos sino también para nosotros
como docentes no porque sé que muchas
veces no tenemos el tiempo para poder
realmente atender las necesidades de
cada unos alumnos más cuando tenemos 150
alumnos no durante un año escolar
entonces los invitamos a hacer parte de
esta capacitación
khan academy va a reconocer sus
esfuerzos maestros les van a les va a no
a dar un reconocimiento y bueno siempre
va a estar dispuesto a la plataforma y
la gente que trabaja para khan academy
para ayudarlos y noia y acompañarlos en
todo este proceso de aprender a utilizar
la plataforma dentro de su salón
el tercer módulo viene ya esté pronto en
un futuro en octubre septiembre octubre
el objetivo ahí va a ser motivar a
nuestros alumnos cómo crear ceremonias
para reconocer los logros y los
esfuerzos de los alumnos en tu plantel
entre escuela la preparación para no
para exámenes etcétera y finalmente
reconocer el esfuerzo de todos ustedes
que están participando en esta
capacitación algo que quieras añadir
christine sobre este programa
no está bien es un programa de
capacitación como docentes en méxico
méxico
van a recibir reconocimientos para tu
esfuerzo y por esto es muy importante
que estás registrado en el formulario
que vamos a compartir al final de esta
capacitación excelente entonces les
vamos a compartir este enlace si ustedes
no se han registrado en esta
capacitación los invitamos a que lo
hagan para que además así podamos
hacerles llegar ya a los en los enlaces
de los webinars que ya tuvieron lugar
entonces más adelante vamos a compartir
esto con ustedes
otra cosa maravillosa que está pasando
ahorita en kant academy es campeonato si
ustedes no saben que es campeonato bueno
aquí tenemos un vídeo corto de sal
acan que es el fundador de khan academy
este programa de campeonato es de verdad
una manera de comenzar el año escolar
con el pie derecho si ustedes quieren
como fortalecer desde un principio la
relación con su salud
crear una mente de trabajo en equipo no
de trabajar algo juntos no desde el
principio de clases y crear esa mente
triunfadora en sus alumnos esa mente del
reto de trabajar en equipo de no de
luchar por un objetivo del conjunto de
verdad que campeonato es el programa
ideal para lograr esto no entonces les
pongo aquí el vídeo de salt card con
este mensaje que nos dejan
hola
profesores de mexico los invito a
también hato de carga
extreme sports active también a dos
cargas
[Música]
exacto
hola soy leonor de khan academy en
mexico para este regreso a clases
khan academy lanzará un reto a nivel
nacional para impulsar el aprendizaje de
los estudiantes
por primera vez en méxico los profesores
de matemáticas y ciencias podrán
participar en el campeonato de canacar
de manos se trata de un programa de 10
semanas en el cual los profesores podrán
aprovechar el contenido de la plataforma
e impulsar así el aprendizaje de sus
estudiantes con un reto muy divertido al
inscribirse los profesores podrán
agregar a sus alumnos asignarles tareas
y ejercicios personalizados y revisar su
progreso como parte exclusiva del
campeonato tendremos una serie de
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
que hemos diseñado con un grupo de
investigación de la universidad de
stanford estas actividades fueron
pensadas para ayudar a los estudiantes a
desarrollar habilidades y estrategias
para tener mentes más fuertes y superar
retos los alumnos ganarán premios y
medallas virtuales para celebrar su
esfuerzo su dedicación
les compartimos un ejemplo de la emoción
que este programa ha generado en brasil
y en eeuu
en campeonato correrá del 10 de
septiembre al 16 de noviembre las
inscripciones se abren en tres juegos el
programa es 100% gráfico y online visita
www.xoom.com peonato punto o hereje e
inscríbete se parte de este reto único
para este regreso a clases
vamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno pues es un mensaje la verdad muy
fuerte muy poderoso a mí me emociona
muchísimo porque siento que si es una
una oportunidad magnífica para que
nuestros alumnos se enganchen empiezan
el año motivados a saber yo sé que a
todos nos cuesta no el regreso a clases
no solamente a los maestros también a
los jóvenes no a nuestros niños estos
campeonatos es este programa de 10
semanas para impulsar el aprendizaje
para motivar a nuestros alumnos para
comenzar el año escolar con el pie
derecho señores va a combinar una serie
de actividades como decíamos en el vídeo
de mentalidad de crecimiento que son
actividades no de matemáticas ni de
ciencias son mentalidades creadas con el
objetivo de ayudar nuestros alumnos a
superar retos a no quedarse atorados en
la frustración de no poder resolver un
único ejercicio o del fracaso no para
poder crear en ellos la habilidad de
desarrollar estrategias de aprendizaje
entonces es un programa muy completo que
nos va a ser
a través de todo el ciclo escolar pueden
participar alumnos de cualquier año
escolar desde primaria hasta
bachillerato las inscripciones ya están
abiertas desde el momento que ustedes
entran a la plataforma ya tienen ahí el
botón para inscribirse así directamente
recuerden antes borrar todas sus clases
muertas porque porque automáticamente
una vez que ustedes se inscriban todas
las clases que ustedes han creado en su
cuenta automáticamente van a entrar a
participar en el campeonato el reto
comienza el 10 de septiembre tiene una
duración de 10 semanas 10 semanas
termina el 16 de noviembre
está pensado como les digo para motivar
a nuestros alumnos y se va a adaptar a
cualquier necesidad de la escuela porque
porque la plataforma está abierta en
todo momento a toda hora y disponible en
cualquier lugar entonces cómo pueden
participar ustedes como profesor es bien
sencillo eliminen sus clases viejas van
a crear sus clases nuevas inscriban sea
campeonato y después lo único que tiene
que hacer es durante las 10 semanas el
campeonato ustedes lo que van a hacer es
asignar tres recursos mínimo por semana
a todos sus estudiantes y yo aquí quiero
remarcar el todos porque necesitamos la
participación de todos ustedes van a
poder tener acceso a una vez que se
escriban a lo que es un tablero de
progreso en este tablero los alumnos van
a ir viendo su progreso y van a ir
viendo que no su puntaje a través de los
siete niveles que dura no por los que
tiene que pasar campeonato para que
ellos logran el 100% del puntaje
necesario en cada uno de los niveles se
necesita la participación del 100% de
los
esto es para motivar a aquellos alumnos
que generalmente sabemos que tenemos no
también en el salón de clases alumnos
que no les gusta participar que son un
poquito a lo mejor hasta el menos
motivados un poquito más flojos o lo que
sea pero aquí vamos a motivar a todos a
que todos sean parte de este éxito y de
este lado ustedes van a estar recibiendo
datos información sobre cada estudiante
y su progreso para apoyar el aprendizaje
como alumnos que tienen que hacer
únicamente responder y contestar las
tres actividades que su profesor le
asigne cada semana esto lleva más o
menos un tiempo de media hora sosa
significa media hora en la plataforma a
la semana que honestamente les digo no
es nada no es muy poco los alumnos
terminan haciéndolo más porque continúan
enganchados y motivados y siguen
practicando etcétera y terminan
practicando mucho más que eso no pero el
requisito al menos es media hora lo que
equivale a las tres actividades
asignadas por el profesor por semana
y también contestar las respuestas de
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento que le asigne su profesor ha
medido que a medida que ellos van
ganando puntaje y van logrando los
objetivos ellos van a ir recibiendo
premios digitales que fueron creados
específicamente para este programa no y
las escuelas que alcancen más metas van
a recibir un paquete sorpresa de khan
academy al igual que aquellos docentes
que registren o que participen en
campeonato con más de tres clases
y bueno con esto nos queda y lo que
queremos es motivarlos a que se
inscriban a campeonato ya ya empezamos
las clases ya es momento de crear sus
clases eliminar las viejas invitar a sus
alumnos y dar ese paso tan importante
para formar parte de este increíble reto
que con el que estamos comenzando el año
escolar queremos apoyarlos acompañarlos
motivarlos que queremos que ustedes como
docentes sepan que khan academy está
detrás de ustedes apoyándolos y siempre
motivados
cristiana alguna pregunta comentario
tenemos una pregunta de idioma de los
vídeos
la mayoría de vídeos que están en inglés
no están en español o no están
subtitulados a casos son diferentes eso
es una pregunta que tenemos
la mayoría de los vídeos que están en
obviamente no están en la plataforma de
español están en español ya traducidos
al español no
habrá todavía no hay mucho por hacer ya
y todavía mucho trabajo por hacer habrá
todavía vídeos que hay que agregar
vídeos que hay que cambiar
khan academy siempre está pidiendo
voluntarios porque como les digo ustedes
lo saben khan academy es una plataforma
gratis entonces siempre está solicitando
no de voluntarios que quieran ayudarlos
no va a trabajar con estos vídeos a
traducir vídeos del área que continua
la manera que estamos traduciendo los
vídeos es a través de la fundación
carlos de métodos gracias a ellos
tenemos la mayoría de nuestro contenido
en español y a cuando estás en la página
ese punto canacar mi punto hereje solo
va a saber que hay vídeos en español
exacto entonces esa es una tarea que
continúa
constantemente están añade añadiendo se
disculpen más y más vídeos en este
idioma
al igual que artículos al igual que los
recursos en general
exacto además preguntas
pues agua no si no hay más preguntas lo
que queremos terminar con esta
información
a todos aquellos digamos que no se han
registrado en el programa de
capacitación que no lo han hecho por
favor complete en este formulario
utilizando el correo electrónico que
utilizaron para abrir su cuenta en khan
academy por favor utilicen el mismo para
nosotros así poder registrarlos y
detectarlos al hacerlo estarán
recibiendo información sobre esta
capacitación sobre los módulos
anteriores que ya tuvieron lugar y les
daremos les haremos llegar también
información sobre el siguiente módulo y
los siguientes webinars para responder
sus preguntas etcétera entonces les
dejamos aquí el enlace para registrarse
al programa de capacitación si no lo han
hecho hagan luchar no ya inmediatamente
y también este es el enlace también les
dejamos aquí el enlace para un documento
con la información del programa con que
ustedes entre en este documento ahí le
pueden poner en favoritos etcétera
nosotros constantemente estamos
añadiendo ahí información clave
no a este documento sobre este programa
de seis meses que tienen la duración de
seis meses durante estos seis meses
recibirán retroalimentación recibirán
tips recibirán haremos y daremos
respuesta a sus preguntas a sus dudas
etcétera
lo importante aquí es que sigan los
pasos en el módulo 1 para que aunque no
hayan participado en el módulo 1 en vivo
puedan recibir también su primer
reconocimiento antes del primero de
septiembre y para el módulo 2 antes del
primero de octubre
y bueno por nuestra parte es todo
nuevamente les recordamos cuál es el
enlace para la plataforma en español que
es ese punto khan academy punto org y
para aquellos que no saben fundación
slim ha creado también un enlace para
que nuestros alumnos puedan entrar desde
su celular a khan academy sin tener que
utilizar sus datos esto es también muy
útil en el caso de escuelas que tenemos
problemas con internet entonces es en
ese punto cero punto khan academy punto
org es algo que les pedimos compartan
con sus alumnos para que puedan entrar a
la plataforma sin la preocupación de
estar utilizando sus datos desde su
celular también les dejamos este correo
o la arroba khan academy punto org al
cual pueden a dirigir todas sus
preguntas dudas sugerencias comentarios
etcétera
por mi parte entonces es todo no me
queda más que agradecerles su esfuerzo
su interés no su motivación es realmente
el que estén en este webinar no es una
muestra de su compromiso con la
educación de sus alumnos con la
educación del país en general muchas
gracias
christina gracias por todo no sé si
quieres añadir algo nuevo gracias por
venir y estamos en contacto y también
esta capacitación es una grabación
entonces pueden usarla el enlace para el
youtube vídeo para ver la capacitación
otra vez y también pueden compartir la
capacitación con otros docentes y
seguimos en contacto van a recibir más
información a través de su correo si
estás participando en el programa de
capacitación y mucha suerte esta semana
y estamos aquí para apoyarles entonces
muchísimas gracias por
y mucho éxito a todos gracias y bajado